it is really difficult for me to pick my
favorite decade of cinema
my favorite decade of movies
i mean every decade there are new
storytellers that are pushing the limits
of cinema the 40s anything in the
screwball era
because all of the women in those movies
were brilliant and witty and charming
and glamorous the era that has kind of
been most influential to me is probably
french new wave getting experimental
trying something new understanding the
power
of
film to make meta critiques of the world
for me my favorite decade of movies is
from 1965 to 1975 because you had
filmmakers that were
pushing against the
hollywood big star-driven style of
movie-making to me what the 70s
represents is really the birth of
independent cinema it's kind of a
toss-up between the 70s and 80s terms of
endearment in the 80s to the godfather
movies in the 70s and so many others the
ones that affected me the most were the
ones in the 80s that's where i grew up
back to the future indiana jones e.t
ferris bueller the breakfast club
um brewster's million
just all these beautiful films never
ending story goonies i miss stand by me
i miss like
groups of kids just discovering and and
being positive about the possibility of
discovery and i miss that about the 80s
i'm a 90s baby so
first wife's club house dela got her
groove back
primary colors mike nichols
the answer is the present time because
of the increasing number of
films
about and by women and people of color
things that have never been seen before
you